in steps adam duvall
home run last night got marlins back to
4-3 that was the final score however
and duvall drives another one
deep left field second night in a row
with a home run from adam duvall
duvall does it all again
the first pitch he sees four scene
fastball splits the plate goodbye
oh and two on jazz who hits a high fly
ball this one deep to right field and
that is into the upper deck
jazz chisholm junior three-run bomb oh
yeah
now that's how you lean on an o2 pitch
the longest home run at low depot park
this year a slider splits the plate
backs up just a bit and unloads
upper deck
can i amend what i was talking about
when i said the marlins aren't the team
to live and die by the three-run home
run i think rogers who uh
isn't exactly high energy out there he's
more of a focus type is there another
one this one out to left center
oh look out autonation alley three
homers in the inning for the marlins
the marlins have unloaded
some of the longest home runs we've seen
at lone depot park this season
have happened in this inning 4 26
for starling martay
my goodness
they are all over
chi-chi gonzalez tonight bringing the
two out run
and first pitch swinging out to center
field daza gives it a ride marty near
the wall leaps and he makes the catch at
the top of the wall starling martay
oh man
he makes it look easy doesn't he he's
going to impress us with his defense
look at the route nice and clean back to
the warning track back to the wall in an
easy jump times it perfectly i've been
here before it's a walk in the park no
home run for you
another strikeout for trevor rogers
who's special in his own right that's
his fifth
roger's going to pick up that fifth
strikeout on a fastball way outside
footy's
little half swing knows as he's swinging
he probably didn't want to but this is
between like 12 and 13 starts for these
two guys now through five with the six
run lead
rogers in line for another win
they might get a run right here that's
going to drop in for a base hit al
farrow around third and jose devers has
himself an rbi single seven nothing
miami now devers on for the third time
tonight his second hit of the ball game
fastball up about bell tie good swing
mention that uh center field approach
tonight with the marlins against chichi
in the arsenal
birdie base hit right center field
devers rounding second he'll go to third
daza cut that one off debra's never
stopped here comes the throw
he's in there safely
the foot feels fine eight nothing
john bertie swinging the bat again
picking on a slider line drive to right
i mean this ball
was a rocket now watch devers
he's off and running he knows there's
two outs but there's no let up around
third base maybe for just a split second
but trey did a fantastic job of speeding
him back up again
that one gets away and here comes jazz
he's in to score
up to second goes martay marlins take a
nine-nothing lead well capitalizing on
the little things tonight are the
marlins three hits for starling marta
tonight another big day for him
this one is gonna get down into the
corner for aguilar
waited a while
but he will get the rbi double
he was just tattooing balls all night
finally has something to show for it
marlins get into the double digits it's
10-0 yeah 13 hits now in the ball game
plenty of extra base hits home runs
doubles
doing it all
alfaro a couple of hits in this one a
single in the third double and a run
scored in the fifth
and that's a base hit into left field
three hits for alfaro
here comes diaz he will score and jorge
alfaro drives in another it's 11 to
nothing three consecutive hits
[Music]
brennan rogers pinch hitting and that
ball deep to left field that's gone
brendan rodgers with his first road home
run his second career home run and he
does it in his home state
and another pinch hit home run
how about brendan rodgers off the bench
and i think you can hear some rogers
fans screaming that down there and i
don't blame him that's pretty cool it's
right out of the hand
i mean it was center cut
the subaru strike zone and he didn't
waste any time that's the 13th road home
run this year for the rockies good for
brendan rodgers
early in your career
with the chopper over to third that'll
bring the run home so rockies
get two runs across the plate and daz
adds an rbi well after being robbed his
last time up it's good to see dazza
get the rbi
and rogers will get a hit and bring a
couple runs
at least one
hold up the runner at third
station to station yes you have to it's
four batters four hits for the rockies
man in the air to left field
and the rockies are going to go for it
with tapia
he's safe at home
sacrifice rbi for ryan mcmahon you know
give
mack the opportunity to have that
sacrifice fly
it's gonna have to take a perfect throw
good hustle good speed even though
sierra is working behind it the throw is
off line mack his 34th rbi
to third bertie makes the play gathers
himself throws a strike across the
diamond and it's
a marlins win they take two out of three
from the rockies
everything goes their way today a great
start from trevor rogers three home runs
in the second inning alone
and they get out to the 11-4 win
and take two out of three from colorado
a nice series
and now they will rest up and get ready
for the braves again they've always said
it's a measuring stick against atlanta